and suck arrived valve found out that
when i saw me nice with
there is a container lit element
backed up not just stupidly repair
vx here time tactic moments from you goin'
on it was not happen units of may be
water is true
gives it news one 1 person is  life is
marwis
it seemed that this is the most important thing that is
happening in my life and that I should
be here and everything else that I
was doing before it seemed to
lose its meaning and opened facebook and
saw that dispersal had begun, just now
thousands of policemen are
beating protesters, breaking barricades I
then I made one of the most difficult
decisions in my life,
I got dressed and arrived here at night, the
biggest action of the automaidan,
it was a Zhiguli ride, it took place on
December 29,
then, according to various estimates, there were from 2 to 4
thousand cars that you took
part in the action, it really was
a lot of
me  I met one guy on the
Maidan and his name is Seryozha Nigoyan, this is a
20-year-old guy from the Dnipropetrovsk
region on January 22
I wake up and read messages that
there are the first people killed on Hrushevsky, I was just
insanely shocked because as a
guy of 20 years old he has his whole life
ahead of me, my close friend and I defended the
Maidan
during the assault on February 18, 19
at night, a guy died next to me, he is a
programmer from Kramatorsk Donetsk
areas in the east,
thanks to the maidan revolution of dignity
, a lot of new faces of
people who were not associated with the
oligarchs
who were not part of some
political project maidan
dima sew a dc site from the species very
jess impala are dead
adapter lot of war and positive has been heard for
years  so in general I’m alive I’m very
nostalgic for the Maidan I miss that
moment I really want to return to
the time when we stood shoulder to shoulder with each other
it was a moment of good and evil of the struggle of life
and death and but a very honest moment
ukraine to be an excerpt of
ukraine i  tied up opened up out of the
american gum any lan party
john thailand worth found in dice
sa  te it is impossible
infiniti welcome to point and i get mine